so the question is can twitter actually  ban the president of the united states  from its platform and a whole bunch of  the president's supporters well  do you think that you could ban someone  from making a speech inside of your home  because that's kind of the same  issue twitter is a private company and  the first amendment  doesn't prohibit private companies or  individuals from controlling  their own private property frankly if  the government could control  what a company like twitter says that  probably itself would be a violation of  the first amendment so  what twitter has done in banning a whole  bunch of people doesn't violate the  first amendment and it doesn't violate  the communications decency act section  230 in fact  cva 230 has nothing to do with this  whatsoever  but anyway stay tuned for more election  coverage and i'll see you  in court